[Music]
hey man thanks for being with us it's
awesome um so you've
written um you and I've told you this
personally I think I reached out to you
which I almost never do um I this is in
the top five most important books I've
read in the last decade and um I told
you I finished the Comfort crisis and I
immediately walked into my son who was
12 at the time I was like you have to
read this book and then um I did
something I almost never do I bought
aa's book and I bought like out of my
own money I bought your book and what
most like Insider baseball when
somebody's getting going to press tour
they often will send out a bunch of
copies and I don't want to wait I was
like no no no I have to have this book
at my house and it's another just
Masterpiece dude it's so good and I
trust you enough I sent you an early
copy of mine and you said I think these
things overlap a lot and this morning I
just sat there as I was going over notes
for this and I thought oh my gosh you
just wrote a better version of of the
book I was trying to put together that's
not true it is but you you um so I'm
excited to dig into this I want to start
with
um a new picture of addiction I've
struggled with it you've been really
open about your adventures with
addiction and I want to frame up
addiction 101 was moral failure forever
if you have an addiction if you can't
stop drinking if you can't stop looking
at pornography if you can't stop
something it's cuz you're weak and you
suck and you're a bad person right and
then there was this shift and I've heard
it a couple different ways but the the
one that makes the most sense
is the only path towards compassion in
our country both with theological with
with faith communities and with the
medical community is to label something
a disease if I stamp it with disease
then the church is like oh you're not a
bad person then you can come to a
Recovery Group at our building or if
it's not a moral failure if it's a
disease then health insurance will cover
it right and so we've lived under this
disease model and quietly over the last
probably 20 years working with college
students which is a huge that's that's
where this the epicenter of some of this
starts it's been this very
disempowering students come in slumped
over right not like I have a huge test
and I'm gonna go get it or you talk to
students right before the bar exam and
they're scared to death but they're also
like I'm gonna get this thing
students coming in saying I got a
disease I've got a thing and it's just
just going to be my life and it's it's a
it's a giving up and then there's been a
different conversation maybe the last 10
or 15 years and it's funny because I
used to always tell college students
parents um hey your kid's drinking
because it works it works it works great
until it doesn't right until it kills
you like cocaine is incredible it works
until until it kills you right and I had
never seen it laid out out and then
there's some authors that have said you
know addiction is just connection and
that's not that doesn't go far enough so
paint us a new picture because I I feel
like both the psychiatrists that I'm
talked to Behind Closed Doors the
psychologist and and medical researchers
that I'm talking to and then folks like
you and I who have experienced this and
who meet with other people regularly and
you travel the world for this book um
paint us a new picture of what addiction
might actually be
so yeah you have to start with um I
think you have to go back in history and
you have to look at um how have humans
traditionally use
substances and in scarcity brain I argue
we've been using substances for millions
of years as survival tools so if you
think about alcohol alcohol's role um as
humans were evolving is that it would
give off a scent uh from rotting fruit
you needed food you couldn't find it
right so you smell this you're like oh
that's food that's going to keep me
alive so you go eat the food right um we
app fall from a tree and they just sit
on the ground exactly they start to they
to ferment you smell that it's like bam
we just found a lot of food great uh
things like cocaine so for example
cocaine is made from coca leaves now
coca leaves are still used as basically
like coffee in um a lot of countries in
South America because it increases your
focus a little bit right now the actual
cocaine component is very very minimal
so we've always used these things to
survive so with the example of the cocoa
Leaf hones your focus on a long hunt it
keeps you going when you're in these
long searches for food in the past when
food was scarce Etc and you can
basically apply that logic to most
substances um but I think what's
different is that today we've sort of
scaled up the psychoactive component and
made it just abundant anywhere right so
it's very easy to get it's cheap and the
part that um yeah makes you feel
something is very strong yeah so we
still use these as tools though right
I'll you you mentioned uh me I'll take
me as an example I don't drink anymore
but the reason I started drinking is
because it enhanced my life made your
life better for AAS made my life better
full stop and we don't talk about that
enough exactly and how did it make it
better A lot of I mean so I've had to
unpack why I drank in the first place um
if I was at a social event it was a
social lubricant um but also I've always
been a person who is drawn to sort of
extreme experience
right like still today I go on these
long back country hunts or I'll go to
these countries that where there's a lot
a lot happening you know um and alcohol
can alcohol gave me that this sort of it
sort of lessened the rain and it was
like anything could happen if you have a
bunch of drinks you don't know what's
going to happen like you're going to be
up for anything and that improved my
life now at a certain point that stops
working right you keep trying to chase
that um good thing that you get from it
over and over and over and eventually it
starts paying back now the the the
problem is that you've learned this
behavior that you are absolutely
convinced and have all this past
evidence improves your
life and if you are an addict using your
substance of choice or behavior of
choice it still enhances your life in
the short term it does so even when I
was at my worst with
drinking if I took a drink my life would
get better at least in the short term
the problem is is that it begins to
create long-term problems the evidence
mounts on the other side like this isn't
helping right right right and it's hard
to it's hard to split that apart yeah
you can't see that in the moment because
you've learned this thing that always
worked and then it stops working and
you're like well why isn't this working
anymore maybe I just need to try it
again and let's do more yeah let's do
more maybe I just didn't do enough right
right uh and so that's a hard cycle to
get out of I think it's more I really
think of addiction as more a
um in a way in the addict's mind it's
kind of a solution to problems um but I
think really what underlies it is it's a
symptom of something else you're trying
to take care of so for me it was just
that like I kind of had a boring life at
the height of my drinking right like I
didn't have a fulfilling job I wasn't
able to get out and do these other
things that would have given me this
like stimulation that I needed to thrive
as a human being and I could find that
um through alcohol even though it was
you know leading to problems in the long
term but it could be it could be any
behavior for other different people you
know you you and I had dinner last night
and we were talking about our
jobs I think that's an important thing
to put a to put a pin in your job at the
time was like a great job and probably
one you were pretty excited to get right
I mean you were a writer for a
prestigious publication I am 100%
confident I read your articles back at
my house cuz I subscribed to several of
the magazines you were a part of
creating and so how much of that boring
job is is a gap between if I get this
job then I'm going to be good and I get
this job and then all a sudden it's like
oh I do this for the rest of my life we
used to joke with actors with my acting
students like hey if you go to Broadway
and you get cats congratulations you're
a cat for next 30 years of your life
twice a day you'll never have a weekend
again like you you got there and it's
like oh gosh you know I mean but how
much of that boredom there's reality
it's just punch and punch and punch but
there had to be annoying sense of Oh I
thought when I got
here that then I'd be okay with Michael
well I think that that's a story of a
lot of different things in life right so
when I was reporting the Comfort crisis
for example I travel to Bhutan and uh I
go meet with this guy who's Kempo in the
Buddhist face so this is like pretty
high up and um he had lived in America
for a while uh he was the he was a
boyfriend of the translator for the doy
Lama so he'd lived in Atlanta he'd kind
of seen how Americans live and now he's
back in Bhutan and he lives in this
Shack that's like on a cliff there's not
electricity it's like a bucket system
for water and he looks at me and he goes
you know a lot of times uh people in the
west they live life like it's a
checklist and once you check the box oh
that's what's going to make me happy but
then you check the box and you
go what what's that other box there
what's the next one I can check and then
it's that search right and so it kind of
is this constant uh dissatisfaction can
happen but I think that in my case um
yeah you know I thought that this like
oh I got this job that everyone's heard
of this place that I work at I'm doing
all this writing but the reality was is
that it wasn't as exciting as you might
think it never is yeah you know I had um
I couldn't write things that I actually
wanted to write about a lot of times I
had editors who would chop it up um I
couldn't get out in the world and meet
like I got into journalism to go to go
places to be on the ground to meet
people to learn information and I
couldn't do a lot of that and um yeah it
just wasn't as exciting as you might
think on paper and so in order to find
that excitement well Friday and Saturday
let's go out to the bars let's drink a
bunch let's see what's going to happen
right it very much was a ro the dice
totally it's like you don't know what's
going to happen you might close down
this bar you know singing Friends in Low
Places with some people you've never met
and like wow that's crazy or it might be
like you know oh we're going to go into
this totally new area of town and like
we're going to this place and there's
just all these different things or it
could even be writing right I could sit
down and crank out these words that I
otherwise might not have had I been
sober and so it's it was very much um an
exploration of the edges in a way that
uh ultimately led to long-term problems
so you know addiction would we wouldn't
even call it addiction substance use
wouldn't be a problem if like yeah had a
bunch of drinks and then I went and
volunteered and then I donated some
money to charity and then I all these
good things right the problem is is that
it leads to behaviors that aren't good
for society often
so I think the scary thing about framing
addiction as first a behavior that works
so if I'm talking to a mom and a dad and
has a 12-year-old that's already showing
signs of
addiction it's easy to want to blame a
12-year-old want to blame the substance
and not ask the harder question which is
what is happening in that kid's world
that their body is finding Avenues to
escape from like whether that's getting
bullied at school whether that's y all
keep fighting whether that's dad you're
not at home and that kid feels that
tension and if I look at I'll just use
the United States if we look at the
escalating addiction rates across the
board on Netflix hours work pornography
drugs whatever I want to say I think the
easy
solution is it's a disease the easy
solution is well you're bad and you're
bad and you're bad the harder question
is what kind of culture have we created
that everybody has everything and
they're so desperate to escape from it
that to me is a scarier question
culturally right it takes harder work
it's not as black and white yeah right
so humans we don't like uncertainty we
don't like complexity it's much easier
if you can just say yep bad person wrong
decision oh absolutely
100% a sick person it's a disease um I
think kind of what we're getting at here
is usually there's some underlying
reason a person would use a substance or
do a behavior in the first place and
it's probably going to be different for
everyone but uncovering that is um is
difficult work it's it's not really fun
no uh so I think that part of getting
sober is having to ask those hard
question questions why am I using this
in the first place so I think addiction
basically needs three things to happen
you need to have a person who is in pain
or has problems you need um a lack of
being able to solve those problems in a
better way or deal with that pain in a
more productive way not a lot of outlets
and then you need a substance that
quickly solves that problem that's
abundant more or less and you see that
that's like the story of most drug
epidemics right so in the book I travel
to Iraq there wasn't much addiction
there for a long time a lot of that was
because uh Saddam ruled with a iron fist
then what happens is you have the US
military Invasion so it destabilizes the
country you have a lot of people who
have lived through the trauma of a war
for a long time and then um in 2017 the
country Syria Falls and they basically
become a narco state so their main
export right now is this drug called
captagon which is this new sort of uh
it's analogous to methamp methy yeah
it's methy yes um and it starts floating
over the borders so you have this
population of people who have all these
traumas from war there's not a lot of
great outlets for that in Iraq it's not
like there's you know Psychiatry offices
on every corner that would help them
find another way out of that and then
you have this substance flood in that
immediately gets you out of your
problems at least in the short term it
allows you to sort of escape from that
and so because of that you see addiction
really Spike same thing with um you know
why did did the opioid epidemic really
boom in a lot of the places that used to
be steel manufacturers it's like well
all the jobs leave took away people's
purpose yeah you're jobless you're
hopeless and then all of a sudden we get
this flood of opioids and that can solve
a lot of problems that were brought on
by not having a sort of Bright Horizon
to look out onto right it's like a very
dark Horizon to be like well I've lost
my job there's no more jobs coming in I
don't have any other skill than this one
that I've spent my whole life learning
and that's terrible like how am I going
to spend my time and then this thing
comes in it makes you feel better in the
short term and I like to
extrapolate like a completely burn to
the ground Iraq and them trying to
figure out what's next and then a burn
to the ground Appalachia right here's
these manufacturing jobs and they're
just gone overnight we Shi them overseas
I like to take those cuz they're outside
the bell curve and then shift it to that
more common quiet life of
desperation you may not be doing opiates
but Netflix has taken you don't even
have to change channels anymore it just
starts the next show for you and your
husband's always going to be a little
bit grumpy your wife's always going to
be a little bit distant your kids are
always going to want to hang out with
their friends more than you they're
always going to have their faces buried
in a screen and so you may not be you
know snorting ad all off your counter
but you can disappear in your own life
right and it's these I'm just going to
you know what I'm not good at with my
I'm not good at being a parent I'm not
good my wife clearly doesn't like me I'm
going to spend more time at work CU I
know I'm good there right and in the
short term I make a little bit more
money I get a little more accolades and
in the long term I create a home that my
kids don't want to come back to after
college right so it cost me everything
because I become addicted to this or
whatever I become addicted to just
checking out right and I think it's easy
to point fingers at alcohol it's easy to
point fingers at new drugs it's easy to
point fingers at opiates it's harder to
point fingers in the mirror and say like
what am I using in my day-to-day life
for me it was food like what am I using
in my life to not be present with
discomfort right and that's a gnarly
place to find yourself I like what you
mentioned that three prong of approach
to addiction because to me the answer is
in the middle everybody's going to
experience pain all of us yeah and
there's always going to be Outlets it's
that middle one which is
how can I go get tools right how can I
go fill my toolkit up Beyond just Rage
or some substance what can I what can I
fill the bag up with and you do that so
great here kind of unpacking
that